Hey welcome to what is sort of like a
new series on this channel where I
reminisce about the past we've done a
couple of these with horror games and
here's one I really want to revisit LSD
dream emulator this game sort of has a
cult following because of how much it
stands out there's really no game like
this it's basically drugs I'm kidding
but it's very similar a lot of people
seem to think
LSD stands for well you know drugs it
stands for the drug but it's really just
a dream emulator that happens to be
psychedelic according to developers we
swear it has nothing to do with LSD
basically the game is based of one of
the designers dream journal that he kept
going for a decade basically he would
wake up and write down what his dream
was about and this game is a reflection
of that and basically because of how
trippy it is and how freaky it is cuz
there's a lot of stuff in this game that
doesn't make any sense a lot of people
treat this as a horror game and I played
this game back in the day when I
mentioned before in a previous video all
I did was play horror games on this
channel back in the day was the only
thing I did and I was so desperate to
find horror games to play because they
didn't used to be many horror games so I
played this game and I treated it like a
horror game and I think I deleted the
video because got so many dislikes
it really didn't get many dislikes at
all I was just such a [ __ ] [ __ ] back
then that oh I got a couple dislike I
guess they hate the video oh god what do
I do
still am a [ __ ] by the way I think
someone ripped off the video you can
check it out
[Music]
let's go deeper I thought I want to
revisit it properly you know I want to I
want to play it again and do it right
and don't treat it like a horror game
because that's not what it is
and then maybe it'll be interesting for
your toe there's your context let's play
the game
can you imagine buying this game to your
kid yeah like my mom would buy me games
base of other people's recommendation
when I was a child and imagine if
someone just kicked them this here get
your childish game he will love it comes
out like mom I said how long is this
intro sequence limbo silent dream okay
so that's what it stands for
sure buddy sure buddy whatever you say
all right so here's starts day one I
love the art direction of this game it's
so timeless okay and I remember this
room this is what Japanese people dream
about I absolutely love the head the
realistic movement of the walking this
is how everyone wants okay here a bird
that's a toilet so you can look up and
down yeah it is something kind of creepy
I woke up great
oh yeah I think if you touch any walls
you just wake up or it changes dream or
something like that
what and then you can run or whatever
this really reminds me a lot of Silent
Hill because you can't see more any much
forward okay I walk through the tunnel
and here we go we ever Egypt oh wow it's
the London Bridge that what it's called
great classic five six music
what is the point drugs then a chicken
what is that you know what out of what
the hell I've got another tunnel should
be going hell yeah they really need to
remake this game I would love to see a
remake of this game okay well I feel
like I'm on drugs
imagine playing this game of drugs and
my red that'd be so super crazy my god
oh wow it just got dark oh I think we
woke up that was her first dream what
the hell who dreams like that I don't
dream like that hell no everyone keeps
talking tell me about their dreams I'm
like dude no what is wrong with you
I'm the sociopath I should have the
weird dreams I have perfectly normal
dreams
I guess you filled the whole thing out
when when you finished a game how long
can you play this game has anyone ever
finished this game
drugs it's my jam
right here this is why I go to the club
it's what I want to dance to okay we're
in the freaky house again I wonder when
something really weird is gonna happen
cuz I'm not weirded out yet why am i
walking so goddamn slow the hell did he
write in his journal
hey I walked up from the roof it was
green good dream to grab the 3d graphics
are really something feels so immersing
into this I woke up I guess I guess I
woke up elephants oh wow it is the
elephants
it was elephants you sort of have to
just guess what it is oh god I touched
them oh oh wow okay okay I'm just gonna
kill myself listen I've been tripped out
before okay
this [ __ ] is nothing this game is now
I've actually never seen this room what
kind of drugs were they on when they
made this oh that's right LSD I get it I
keep walking up the stairs
fantastic oh no I just made it to the
room oh I'm never back in this hell this
one of my dreams I wouldn't want to live
I wouldn't want to sleep what is the
goal of the game oh look it's a it's a
thing oh oh oh hello there
excellent we're gonna make a game
everyone listen up we're gonna make jam
let me play my dreams that's right and
we're gonna call it LSD and people are
gonna love it
goddamn it what the hell is that thing
this is some vaporwave [ __ ] look at this
seriously it's the goal just to kill
myself I don't go there I found a bridge
I found a bridge I found a bridge
everyone
oh god that's creepy oh that just the
sound of the bridge scared me
[Applause]
oh whoa what happened what happened
I'm stuck in the left stuck in the left
I'm stuck on back coming Oh goddammit uh
fine I'll go this way
I got care I don't care I'm looking at
myself sleeping Oh God okay now I'm
getting a little trip down and real a
freak that I feel like I'm stuck in
those sonic bonus levels
oh god I'm on a train track I'm gonna
trade jack I'm gonna die I better get
off my god
oh wow it just keeps coming now what the
[ __ ] a ah I'm genuinely creeped out
now you did a game it's not a puzzle to
be solved is there a thing to be done
is there a reason for anything in life
are real just gonna die one day and
nothing will matter this is a nightmare
love I want to die let me just walk into
this wonderful restaurant
well hello that kind sir well how'd she
mean match day how you doing
I want to give me some fine whiskey
okay so thrill I never seen anyone this
happy to see me
incredible it's a giant turtle of course
is a giant turtle when it oh it's a tiny
turtle now it's a tiny turtle everyone I
thought it was joined up when I was a
tiny turtle incredible scientists really
let us so far everything just hurts
everything hurts
[Applause]
oh wow
oh gosh yes I'm so [ __ ] lost I got
goose bumps for real this game is really
something else I don't know if you got
the same experience as me and watching
it but damn I don't think I've ever had
a game do this to me it's so surreal man
I know I'm sound like it's so really
great that's not it at all but um I
don't even know it's sick
I feel weird I feel really strange I
don't know how I am speechless thank you
for watching let me know what other game
you wanted me to reminisce for in the
room the best look like we enjoyed
really appreciate it and Squad fan drugs